aloys brey nokia eine holte es sind
grausame verstörende bilder die sich
unauslöschlich einbringen
vier hunde die ein offensichtlich zahmes
kätzchen angreifen und lebendig
zerreißen
auf geheiß ihres herrchens patrick m
ohne erbarmen vor der seine hunde auch
noch an
[Musik]
unfassbar der 31-jährige ist jäger das
eineinhalb minuten lange video landet
bei der staatsanwaltschaft bad kreuznach
die mutmaßlichen tierquäler droht eine
gefängnisstrafe
es ist ein vergehen nach § 17
tierschutzgesetz das gesetz sieht vor
geldstrafe oder freiheitsstrafe bis zu
drei jahren so der gesetzliche strafraum
daneben sieht paragraf 20
tierschutzgesetz ein tierhalteverbot vor
dass auch via limitiert gegeben werden
kann zeitlich begrenzt aber auch
lebenslang und sich auf alle sämtliche
tiere beziehen kann und berufsmäßigen
umgang mit tieren
bislang schweigt der angeklagte vor
gericht zeigt keine spur von reue
der landesjagdverband rheinland-pfalz
distanziert sich von dem katzen keller
tat wie der angeklagte seine hunde dort
auf diese katze gehetzt hat ist absolut
tierschutzwidrig und mit unserem
selbstverständnis der jäger sollten
sachen tierschutz hundeausbildung
überhaupt nicht vereinbar
immer wieder vor patrick im seine erst
zögerliche stunde an
bis diese das kätzchen regelrecht
zerfetzen tierschützer von peta hat das
grausame video zugespielt bekommen und
umgehend strafanzeige gestellt
wir hatten eine zuspielung von jemandem
aussagen kreisen die wir anonym halten
müssen und diese person hat eindeutig
und genannte als denjenigen der dort
spricht er und die runde aufhetzt für
eine verurteilung reicht das allerdings
noch nicht ein gutachten soll klären ob
es sich bei der stimme im video
tatsächlich um jäger patrick ändern
3 der prozess gegen den mutmaßlichen
killer geht also weiter
peta sprecher dr christian ahlert ist
uns jetzt zugeschaltet die
tierschutzorganisation hat geholfen er
überhaupt diesen schrecklichen fall vor
gericht zu bringen herr doktor alle
guten abend danke dass er sich zeit
nehmen
was ging ihnen persönlich durch den kopf
als sie zum ersten mal diese
schockierende video gesehen haben
ich war natürlich auch absolut entsetzt
die aggressivität mit der der marken
karten die runde in dem video anfeuert
und sie dann ja sogar noch triumphierend
lobt als sie die katze wirklich packen
und in stücke reißen diese aggressivität
geht absolut ins mark also da gewöhnt
man sich nie dran auch wenn man so etwas
schon öfter gesehen hat es ist auch
gerade jetzt noch mal als sie den
einspieler gemacht hatten mir wirklich
kalt den rücken runtergelaufen es wird
sich jetzt aber vielleicht erstaunt zu
hören aber wenn man sich aktiv im
tierschutz befindet dann kriegt man
solche bilder und videos leider gar
nicht so selten zu sehen gerade aus dem
bereich der hobby jagdhunde in
deutschland immer noch auf andere tiere
gehetzt werden dürfen
das heißt wie kommen sie an so ein video
wenn sie sagen das kommt gar nicht so
selten vor dass die zu ihnen kommen wo
finden sie die kursieren die
massenhaftem und im internet massenhaft
ist jetzt im vergleich zu anderen
bereichen der tierquälerei
wahrscheinlich zu viel gesagt aber wir
haben ein whistleblower formular online
über dieses formular werden und jährlich
dreistellige zahlen an die quelle
zugespielt und wir gehen diesen
hinweisen nach und geben sie auch ihr
behörden weiter herr doktor etwas wissen
sie über den man aus diesem video
wir wissen dass es sich um einen 31
jährigen handelt der aus rheinland pfalz
stammen wir wissen dass drei der runde
zu sehen sind auch der gruppe dieses
angeklagt mittlerweile wirklich
zugeordnet werden konnten also steht da
eine verbindung zwischen der person und
zu hören ist und dem angeklagten das ist
und wir wissen auch dass der angeklagte
als sie beschrieben wird als gefährlich
und sogar als unberechenbar er außerdem
der vergangenheit schon gegen ihn
ermittelt zum beispiel wegen beleidigung
körperverletzung tierquälerei und auch
erschlossenen macht also kein
unbeschriebenes blatt ist das jetzt ein
einzelner täter oder kommt sowas ihrer
erfahrung nach massenhaft vor ganz oft
vor ist das ein weit verbreiteter trend
also wie gesagt gerade im bereich der
jagd liegen leider brutale verstöße
gegen den tierschutz häufig nahe da auch
die kontrolle kaum möglich ist im wald
und da wie gesagt da auch die jagd
gesetze leider sehr weit gehen und so
ist es nicht ungewöhnlich dass man auch
so genannten schliefen anlagen zum
beispiel bilder sieht in denen hunde
wirklich die füchse hetzen und an
lebenden füchsen ausgerichtet werden
und es ist auch nicht ungewöhnlich dass
man bilder zugespielt bekommt auf den
sich hunde in füchsen in waschbären in
schweinen verbissen haben was dann auch
häufig natürlich für die hunde
verletzungen mit sich bringt und auch
tödlich ausgehen kann also das ist
leider überhaupt kein einzelfall
was trotzdem man jetzt eine strafe die
staatsanwaltschaft hat in ihrer ersten
äußerung bereits angedeutet dass sie
sollte er nicht geständig seien eine
zweijährige freiheitsstrafe beantragen
will
außerdem steht natürlich ein
tierhalteverbot im raum der mann scheint
ja sehr sehr viele hunde zu besitzen
und er soll dann höchstens noch einen
hund besitzen dürfen die er auch nicht
zur jagd zwecken eingesetzt werden darf
und selbstverständlich würde ihm der
jagdschein und der waffenschein entzogen
werden
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren